The word “jumbo” can roughly be understood
to mean “a large specimen of its kind”
and it’s often posited that the word entered
the English language thanks to an elephant.
While this is certainly a nice story, the
truth is a little more complicated.
First things first, though etymologists are
in agreement that the word “jumbo” in
specific reference to something that is quite
big was popularised by an African bull elephant
called Jumbo, there is evidence that the word
existed long before he was even born.
In the latter half of the 19th century, Jumbo
the elephant was arguably one of the most
famous animals on Earth.
Throughout his life as a zoo attraction and
later a circus performer, he is estimated
to have been seen by several million people.
While nobody is exactly sure when Jumbo was
born, it’s believed that he was captured
as a young calf in 1860 somewhere in East
Africa after his mother was shot by hunters.
In 1862, after travelling hundreds of miles
on foot and by boat, Jumbo was sold to a large
botanical garden in France called the Jardin
des Plantes.
Jumbo’s life at the Jardin des Plantes was
reportedly not so great; along with awful
conditions, Jumbo was constantly overshadowed
by the garden’s two other elephant attractions,
Castor and Pollux (who are themselves famous
for being eaten during the 1870 Siege of Paris).
In 1865, Jumbo was sold to the London Zoo
after years of negotiations spear-headed by
the zoo’s Superintendent, Abraham Bartlett.
Bartlett had supposedly been very annoyed
to learn that the French had managed to get
their hands on the first African elephant
specimen to set foot in Europe; so much so
that he eventually agreed to send the Jardin
des Plantes the following list of animals
in return for the calf:“A rhino, a jackal,
two eagles, a pair of dingoes, a possum and
a kangaroo”.
When the young elephant finally arrived in
London, Bartlett immediately recognised that
it had been poorly looked after and handed
its care off to his most talented zoo-keeper,
Matthew Scott.
Scott, who was noted as having a knack for
understanding animals, quickly bonded with
the elephant and under his expert care, Jumbo
eventually grew to become one of the largest
elephants the world has ever known, standing
at an impressive 12 feet tall in his prime
(later advertised as over 13 ft. tall).
Jumbo’s massive size and gentle temperament
eventually led to him being bought by legendary
circus owner, P.T Barnum in 1882.
The sale of Jumbo caused a considerable stir
in England and the London Zoo was heavily
criticised by the public for daring to sell
him.
You see, during his time at the London Zoo,
Jumbo had become quite a celebrity and boasted
such high-profile fans as Queen Victoria,
who personally petitioned the zoo not to sell
him.
The zoo, however, were worried about Jumbo
entering what is known as “musth“, a condition
that can affect bull elephants resulting in
an increased production of testosterone and
unpredictable, violent behaviour.
Jumbo’s sheer size meant that if he entered
musth, he could have quite literally destroyed
the entire zoo if he felt like it.
He had proven before that he was more than
capable of destroying the doors to his cage
and the chains that were supposed to hold
him in place; so the zoo decided that it simply
wasn’t worth the risk.
Once he got to America, Jumbo’s arrival
was milked for all it was worth by Barnum
who had his image emblazoned on everything
he could find.
Jumbo proved to be one of the most popular
attractions at Barnum’s zoo and he was billed
by the entrepreneur as “The biggest elephant
in the world“.
Sadly, just 3 years later, Jumbo was killed
after being struck by a train and dragged
along for about 300 feet before the train
came to a stop.
Reportedly, as he was taking his dying breaths,
he used his trunk to hold the hand of his
long-time trainer.
Ever the showman, expert marketer, and businessman,
Barnum had Jumbo’s remains preserved and
toured with them for many years.
Back to the topic at hand.
While it’s true that Jumbo was a humongous
specimen, even by elephant standards, and
also that after his death his name came to
be synonymous with anything large, the word
jumbo existed long before he did.
As early as 1823, the word “jumbo” was
a slang term used to describe: “a big, clumsy
person, animal or thing.”
Unfortunately, we’re unable to trace the
meaning back much further than that because
it originated in slang speech, which is so
often notoriously poorly documented.
One origin theory posited by a slang dictionary
published in 1823, with possibly the longest
title of any dictionary in history (80 words),
is
that it perhaps derived from the phrase “mumbo-jumbo”.
Mumbo-jumbo, which many of you will likely
understand as a synonym for something that
is meaningless or intentionally convoluted
and confusing, derives, according to the Oxford
English Dictionary, from “the name of a
grotesque idol said to have been worshipped
by some tribes,” often claimed to have been
called Maamajomboo.
It’s believed the word was adopted by the
English language during the 18th century and
that it may have been used as a derogatory
term to refer to the so-called “incomprehensible”
languages used by Africans.
How the singular word “jumbo” came to
be derived from this phrase isn’t precisely
known.
As for how Jumbo the elephant got his name
in the first place, this is similarly not
known.
One theory is that Jumbo was given his name
by Abraham Bartlett who reportedly just liked
the sound of the word, evidenced by the fact
that he once called a gorilla “mumbo”.
Another theory is that it was actually Jumbo’s
trainer and handler, Matthew Scott, who named
him “Jumbo” after the slang term because
of his clumsy gait and heavy-set frame.
Despite his huge size, Jumbo was a remarkably
calm elephant as long as his trainer was around
and he was known to have given thousands of
children rides on his back throughout his
life.
Matthew Scott and Jumbo shared a very close
relationship throughout their time together
and Jumbo would reportedly throw tantrums
whenever Scott went home.
When Jumbo was bought by P.T Barnum, Scott
was hired to be his keeper simply because
he was the only one Jumbo would listen to.
Abraham Bartlett was so terrified at the thought
of Jumbo going on a rampage if something happened
to Scott that he wrote a letter to the Zoological
Society asking for them to provide him with
a method of killing Jumbo if Scott was ever
injured.
As mentioned, reportedly as Jumbo was taking
his dying breaths, he used his trunk to hold
the hand of Scott.
According to Matthew Scott, he would share
a bottle of beer with Jumbo every night.
Scott claimed one night when he drank the
bottle himself and promptly fell asleep before
giving Jumbo his share, Jumbo gently lifted
Scott out of bed with his trunk and put him
on the floor in front of him.
When Scott woke up, he realised his mistake
and promptly got Jumbo a fresh beer.